you've talked on my show about your
daughter uh
uh georgia before is what is she is she
15 16 how old is she
just turned 16 the conan just just
turned 16.
okay and and how's that going because
she sounds like a character she sounds
uh you you have some good
you have some good stories about her uh
she got into an accident
yesterday oh no i'm sorry can't laurel
canada chandler
good old georgia
she's driving yeah i knew i knew she i
love her
i love my kids i trashed them a lot but
this [ __ ] was not ready to drive
literally we were driving through a
neighborhood one time and she's
her her and i look i was in the back
eyeless sees the sign says deaf child
and georgia goes and isla goes well
that's racist
i was like huh how's that great
it's not racist at all that's what's
wrong with these kids it's not i go isla
they put that sign in georgia goes dad
i'll take this one
she goes isla they put that sign up so
that we know when we're in this
neighborhood
we should lower our radios so we don't
rub it in that we can hear
like that's actually not at all why they
put that sign up there towards you
i go so you know there's a child that
may not hear your car coming so you need
to pay extra attention and she goes
well it sounds like they're making me do
all the work
[Laughter]
i can't believe she's out driving uh it
frightens me and i'm gonna look three
ways before i cross any street now if i
know
if i know she's in town